what does DCA mean
Ah that's a good one so DCA is what I
live by decide what you're going to do
how you're going to do it
commit to that decision
and then apply action
if you can do those three things you
will always succeed and that's always
kind of been my Mantra right so if you
think about
making a movie filmmaking
I decide I'm going to make this movie
okay how are you going to make this
movie I'm going to write this script and
I'm going to break it down into steps
and create a plan
okay great commit you have to now commit
to that plan commit to those steps that
you created and commit to making that
movie
action now I'm moving my body and I'm
I'm moving my fingers I'm making phone
calls I'm sending emails and I'm gonna
do that to be successful so just by
doing those three things and holding
yourself accountable to those three
things you can create a film I always
say like if you can answer this one
question you can make a movie can you
finish it
if you can look in the mirror and say
yes I can finish it then you can make a
movie because if you've already
committed to yourself that you can
finish it then you just gotta start
and a lot of people that collaborate
with me and they know if I decide like
Hey we're going to do this it's as good
as done it's it's as good as done
because I don't make that decision that
I'm gonna do something unless I'm gonna
finish it so if I'm on the fence about
something
ah we don't really know what's going to
happen with that but if I'm like all
right it's go time we're gonna do it
it's as good as done
which of the three do you do you
struggle with or have you struggled with
in the past the D the C A the D
I think
the decision is the hardest
because once you decide
you're allotting your life energy to
that and I think in life we're like a
battery we have so much energy before it
goes to zero
so when you decide that you're going to
do something like when I decided I was
going to do four Migos
I knew it was a massive undertaking
I knew it was dangerous I knew that uh
it was a lot of sweat I knew that it
would take a lot of effort
so I had to decide that I was going to
do it
the once you get past D you've already
gotten to the gate of the house so the
committing in action that's the easy
part because you've already made that
decision
so it's the decision part
have you always been this disciplined
yes
uh
uh I always kept my room clean
in order to make movie in order to make
money growing up in Hawaii we sold food
so my stepmom
uh she didn't have a degree
she
on paper wasn't the smartest but what
she had an abundance was love
and common sense that Common Sense I've
carried with me my entire life
and um
when I would not go to school or say oh
I don't feel good
she would make me make food so we would
make pasteles and ganduli rice and we
would drive from Hilo to Kona and we
would go to all the construction sites
and we would come out and we would sell
food right and I would have to go knock
and go see these people early on
and that's where the nose and the na or
the yes you know we would have to before
we could leave we'd have to sell out the
coolers of food that we made
and that taught me a valuable lesson
that if you don't want to do this for
the rest of your life then you better
get disciplined because you're able to
go a lot further in life on being
disciplined than you are on just being a
wild man
because behind any successful wild man
he has to be somewhat disciplined
because how else did he become
successful and we're not talking about
trust fund or anything you're talking
about like okay he became successful and
now he's wild he's living his best life
let's say
he still had to show up he still had to
create he still had to sell he's still
had to hire the right people so he still
had to be disciplined to do whatever it
is that they accomplished
did you like Pursuit of Happiness
I did
but I would never make a pursuit of
happiness so
80s 90s to me were the were the best ERA
of film right and the reason why I say
that is because we had just enough
technology to enjoy everything but we
had enough time to really enjoy it to
talk with your neighbors hey have you
seen this episode of this or have you
seen did you go to the store and rent
this movie so you could sit on a film it
was like a gift that you had that you
can consume right and
those films and those errors in that
time frame
I feel like they didn't really have as
much of a sensor and I I want to say
almost like a responsibility or like a a
filter
that there is today so with Pursuit of
Happiness I
it was a great performance from Will
Smith it was a beautifully shot and
executed film
but
for me I like films that take me away
from the daily life I don't want to see
struggle I don't want to see you know
someone broke and they made it out like
I don't want to see that necessarily I I
like
obviously as creators you create what
you can create so you create the stories
that you're able to create in the in the
space that you're written but if I had
50 million dollars or 100 million
dollars I wouldn't create
you know a story like a Rex park or even
a pizza boy Rick for that matter I would
create Aliens versus Predators you know
um Avatar I like things that expand the
imagination I like things that take you
away from life for a second and teleport
you into a new world I like things that
that that take like humans and really
just multiply them into like this this
different atmosphere so if you think of
Avatar and you think what he James
Cameron was able to create with Avatar I
remember watching it coming out of the
theater like man life seems so boring
because Avatar had these vibrant colors
in this different world that it really
transported you to if you think of you
know something like um
The Matrix Terminator 2 Judgment Day
like these things are so even though
they have human stories right
they're so futuristic and sci-fi and so
out there even like apocalyptic films
that it makes me go like oh wow that's
cool like oh I love that Star Wars you
know anything that that really
takes the imagination to the edge of its
seat is where I would love to be
because I feel like
as humans we all live
struggle
we all live
happiness and pain I don't for me I
don't
enjoy watching
a pure just human story as much
because I want to escape when I watch a
film like if you watch Top Gun man
you're a fighter pilot you're you're in
that chat you know how to fly planes you
hear the sounds and and and you see what
they see from the cockpit it's like yes
I want to experience that
I don't want to experience uh we're
struggling we're eating ramen noodles
and then you know my mom hustled and
made it out and they gave us a better
life
because I lived a lot of that so I don't
I don't need to see it
but
if I'm able to witness oh the
Terminators coming from the future to
take this kid out who's the future
leader and then there's these robots in
this this monster truck is going off of
The Cliff it's like oh wow that is
incredible like I just saw ambulance on
the plane here and that is action pack
from like after the first 10 minutes to
the end of the film where I watch it
like oh my goodness like do you know how
much effort it takes to make a film
that has this much action Non-Stop
for like an hour and a half straight
right I think that you have a greater
appreciation for films
as a creative that's done it
than someone that's only ever watched
from the sidelines because you realize
no matter what level of film it is
it took so much effort
for that film to get made whether the
execution was phenomenal or the
execution
was entry level
it took so many hours
heartache
pain Joy moments to create that project
and I think that once you create
that feeling that a lot of I believe
creators have of
why him and not me
I think that goes away a lot of it
because you understand how much effort
the negativity surrounding films
it goes you're like man it's a good
thousand people like to me it blows my
mind that somebody will pay millions of
dollars for something that one person
Drew on a painting that maybe took him a
hundred hours or took her a hundred
hours
but a movie that took thousands of hours
hundreds of millions of dollars
they won't spend 20 bucks on Blu-ray
and it's
it it almost blows my mind
because
if you think of
subscription-based films like a Netflix
or Tubi or anything like that
or I know Toby's Avon but if you think
of what we have access to when it comes
to films nowadays
there's so much
and it's become so diluted that the
value of films
are not appreciated even though every
single one of us consumes films on a
daily basis
they're not appreciated in the way that
they should be
because could you imagine if tomorrow
all of a sudden films disappeared
I it would be a lackluster
color would would become a little more
dull
but that's because we have so much
access to it in as filmmakers let's say
we put a million dollars into a film
we want people to watch it so bad
to just like because every film you give
like a piece of your soul in it and you
want everybody to watch it so bad that
you're willing to let Netflix scoop it
up for 300 000 and take a 700 000 loss
because you know a hundred million
people can watch it and hopefully
because they watch it that leads you to
your next project
you're willing to take that Gamble
but in reality it's like your film is
worth more than that
it's
it's worth the world in gold
and I think we've lost that as people
we've lost the value of film
I want to see your story though I mean
maybe you said that you don't want to
talk about when you were telling me the
story because this is the first time I'm
hearing that I didn't see that in in the
research that we did I wanted to know
more but again that's that's your life
that's your story but
to me I wanted to follow that little boy
or however old you were going to these
construction sites I mean that's you
know maybe when I get older my mindset
would change uh I know my mindset now at
34 is different than it was when I was
24. very different
um but I think
that
a lot of people probably
live that story right we all we all
struggle in a way we all have our highs
and lows
but I think if I have so many shots to
take when it comes to films because even
if you're at the highest level in a
lifetime
like a Christopher Nolan you only have
so many films in a lifetime that you're
able to make
so if I have those shots I'd rather make
the Inception
I'd rather make you know the Jurassic
Park I'd rather make those things that
really take with a kid watches in they
see Jurassic Park they're they're
enamored and just wowed by the story The
visuals and what they see so then that
expands their imagination
so if I have so many shots
I'd rather do those and fail than to
succeed and make just a grounded story
that we've already seen